read your sword that's it cut again free
your sword cut and we go slow to a wool
and it goes right into that so that's
the first place you seen kima suit you
guys not follow and take it
[Music]
yep to relax okay
and he's here and you analyst Schulman
going to sell beer how do you got it
it is very slow he goes this is Kiba
subbu he goes go this is not ki Masood
he goes up I follow it up and then here
again
same place shomenuchi yo so this
backhand shomenuchi strike written with
shomenuchi place boom boom same exact
thing that is also key mercy I don't
disconnect same thing here when you
clear this half this hand is doing it
too right here sit up like this just a
simple exercise follow it and don't lose
contact with it then extended the whole
body so the whole body is doing it we
don't this contact my moves on at that
so up
[Music]
not like this
do you guys see that okay
that's what you're trying to do okay so
kima soubise underlying concept is
hidden in yon right such as connection
right it's connection between proper
Union young relationships so when he
goes up see how I follow that it can't
be a matter that you're trying to
remember oh he's going to go and then
you do to go like this it's gotta be the
same connection here that I'm not losing
the arm the same thing goes as I go up
follow that time you feel the in space
take it come around same thing take the
arm so it following the in space there
it is seamless goes around following it
connection
okay let's go